finally tonight a special graduation in
birthday blowout for one talented local
kid yeah we're talking about four year
old Justin boom ah he just graduated
from kindergarten and since celebrations
really aren't happening this year his
family decided to organize a special
parade not only for graduating but also
for his upcoming birthday later this
month he even got a special shout out on
a Las Vegas digital billboard way to go
mom and dad Justin is also a published
author and part of today's celebration
was to mark his first Las Vegas line of
books for kids this says hashtag Vegas
strong because we are Vega strong right
Dustin right I just wanted so respectful
especially during this time of the pimp
endemic to do something unique as unique
as 2020 is did we mention he's four
justin has been publishing books with a
little help from his mom for a couple of
years now he just wrote his very own
story for PBS kids so keep an eye out
for this upcoming author Bryan he said I
got a cardboard cutout he's on
billboards he's a novelist he's four